we always see the best of people in
times like this take for example this
video from Orlando Florida there was a
heroic effort to get nursing home
residents to safety as the storm was
barreling in but even as Ian weakened it
did not spare other parts of the State
of Florida I mean we're talking most of
the people who live in the state were
affected our Meg Oliver is in Saint
Augustine on the Atlantic coast Meg how
are things there this morning
David good morning as you can see it's
very calm residents here in St Augustine
got through the worst of the storm last
night yesterday morning I was holding on
to this railing as high winds blew
through over the last 48 hours we have
seen some neighbors just helping in some
of the most unimaginable circumstances
from Orlando
it's Coast in St Augustine all the way
up to Jacksonville
hurricane Ian brought high winds rain
and severe flooding leaving cars
submerged and forcing hundreds of people
to flee their homes
in hard hit Kissimmee First Responders
used airboats to rescue those traps in
some cases people were carried to safety
like this woman crying with relief to
escape the flood waters we're going
through doing house checks if anybody
has any type of medical attention we
took the fire rescue guys with us at a
couple deputies we're going to bring
them out to Higher Ground rescue crews
raced to evacuate residents of this
Orlando nursing home this is probably
one of the worst hurricanes I've ever
experienced in my life this woman and
her 72 year old mother were forced to
swim out a window to reach safety we try
to stay as high as we could but it just
gets to a point where you can't
you can't go anymore you have to like
either swim or drown I didn't Imagine
This
I didn't I didn't see this coming Friday
this is uh this is
unreal in Kissimmee Rufus Gordon had an
emotional reunion with his 87 year old
father Amos who was stuck in high flood
waters they were very very helpful I
couldn't have made it without them the
Gordons are both Navy veterans Rufus had
seen the community come together
reminded him it makes you feel good to
know we still have people that they want
to do what they have to do to help
others
heartwarming indeed now just to put
things into perspective the road below
me was completely flooded yesterday
trapping us inside this hotel for most
of the day that water has receded and
we're learning that businesses plan to
reopen to survey the damage and begin
the cleanup now what remains to be seen
David is across the bridge there on that
Barrier Island whether or not those
low-lying homes are faring as well as we
are here that remains to be seen
glad you're okay Meg thank you very much
it really is incredible how fast the
water not only Rose but receded as well